Hey uh Doctor Michael you and i should stay in touch
time to let go of what you used to be discover
who you're meant to be in the film version of
morbius that we're bringing to you now he's also a
part of a much larger universe if you've seen the
last spider-man no way home trailer you know the
multiverse has officially opened and there's all
kinds of opportunities for villains to meet
up thrive and maybe even nurture their more
sinister intents
Welcome back everyone this will
be my full marvel morbius post credit scene video
i'll explain what's going on there were a lot
of questions there are a lot of easter eggs and
obviously they're trying to tease a bunch of
future big spin-off movies if you're brand new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos careful for spoilers from the morbius
movie if you have not seen it yet because we'll be
talking about everything that happens at the end
they changed the order that a couple things
happened during the movie couple spider-man
easter eggs i'll explain why they did that after
spider-man their way home and the reason for the
delays a lot of it has to do with what happened
during spider-man no way home and the sony people
adjusting what happened during morbius to sort of
coincide with what happened during spider-man no
way home but at the end of the morbius movie matt
smith's hunger villain attacks martine bancroft
morbius's love interest and she lays dying he
comes to her apologizing for what he's done he's
all remorseful what he's put her through and she
inadvertently winds up ingesting a drop of his
blood i think everybody saw the direction this was
going so if it wasn't clear he's not intending to
give her his blood like he wants to get rid of
his condition he's trying to cure his condition
at least presently it's not totally clear if she
was trying to bite his lip to ingest his blood but
she does wind up drinking some of his blood and
that's why at the very end like after another time
jump after morbius had defeated seemingly killing
hunger martine wakes up with the red eyes remember
when morbius transforms into the living vampire
it takes a little while for the transformation
to take effect like it's not an immediate kind
of thing same basic idea with her transforming
into a living vampire it's meant to be a big comic
book easter egg for martine and the morbius in the
spider-man comics another interesting connection
to spider man no way home too when all the purple
tears and reality show up in spider man no way
home at the end and all those versions from the
multiverse show up they're all meant to be classic
versions of the sinister six characters one of
the multiverse characters that shows up is the
six-armed version of spider-man that's the version
of spider-man that they introduced when they
were introducing morbius in the spider man comics
but in future movies when martine comes back
either morbia sequels if they wind up doing those
or if she winds up showing up in the sinister
six movie when she comes back she will have the
same powers as morbia she'll be a living vampire
like him another day walker remember just like
the spider-man comics morbius is not a traditional
vampire so he can walk during the day and there's
no problem and he doesn't have a lot of the
traditional weaknesses that classic vampires do
but he does mention dracula during the events in
the movie and dracula is an mcu character there's
rumors that he's actually going to be one of
the characters in the blade movie the first
mid-credit scene is basically a spider-man no way
home scene they literally copy and pasted some of
the special effects from spider-man no way home or
at least trying to copy them as close as possible
it's implied there is a short time jump later not
a lot of time has gone by like it's pretty quickly
soon after there's a purple rift in the sky just
like the end of spider man no way home denoting
doctor strange's second spell and it's while he's
basically reversing the effects of the first spell
sending all the multiverse characters back where
they came from but remember in the morbius movie
this is happening over their universe's version of
new york city this also confirms that this takes
place after the events of the venom let the b
carnage movie because earlier in the film tyrese's
team also references the events of quote unquote
what happened in san francisco talking about what
happened during the events of venom let there
be carnage an mcu vulture shows up inside their
universe's version of riker's prison so obviously
a lot of questions about this how did it happen
this way the effects of doctor strange's spell
weren't supposed to work like this he's wearing
the exact same white prison jumpsuit you saw him
in in the spider-man homecoming post-credits scene
and he says i hope the food here is better
like he understands kind of what's happened
i do have some issues with their logic because why
would doctor strange's second spell send him away
from his original universe if the second spell
only was meant to reverse the effects of the
first spell making everyone forget a version
of peter parker was a version of spider-man
like why would forgetting about peter parker send
him to another universe the first spell acted like
a multiverse magnet for people who knew a version
of peter parker was a version of spider-man
it didn't have to be mcu peter parker spider-man
that's why all the multiverse villains wind up
showing up from the topee mcguire and andrew
garfield movies because at some point in the
timeline of their films they had learned their
spider-man was their peter parker so technically
per the logic of the spider man no way home movie
writers only the multiverse people from other
universes should have been sent away after the
second spell happened but technically the sony
people are trying to say hand waving logic that a
bunch of people could have also been sent away to
other universes from the mcu that weren't supposed
to be sent away there's a news broadcast about the
prison letting mcu vulture go because in their
universe in the venom universe they had never
had a record about any version of adrian toomes
being arrested so they make it sound like there
is no adrian tomes that originally existed there
so there's not two of them or anything like that
in the second post-credits scene you see morbius
still inside the united states somewhere driving
a porsche which seems like a product integration
like porsche probably paid money to have their
car in the film you think he'd be flying using
his powers but he's been contacted by the mcu
vulture apparently who shows up to speak to him
in this big field and in the scene he's wearing
his mcu vulture suit and a lot of people also
had questions about this like hold on here where
did the vulture suit come from the mcu vulture
suit did not show up in his alternate universe
prison cells so a lot of people are like how did
the suit get there into this universe too was it
transported along with him or did he recreate it
somehow my assumption is that sony is doing more
hand waving logic and saying it's the original
vulture suit from spider-man homecoming and
it was just taken into custody at the original
prison that he went to in the mcu and all of his
personal effects got transported to the alternate
venom universe with him when he got transported
and you also have to remember that there was no
battle of new york inside the venom universe so
there's no version of the chataura that invaded
earth which means that it would have to be the
original mcu vulture suit like his suit contains
a much of repurposed chatauri tech that they
salvaged but he says he's been reading up a lot on
morbius recently he's a big fan of his work and a
bunch of guys like them should team up and take
care of spider-man to which morbius just reacts
saying hmm intriguing like he's interested to hear
more of what the vulture has to say it's meant to
be a big teaser for two different things for their
team up in the sinister six movies that they're
setting up they have planned and it's meant to
confirm that a version of spider-man does exist
inside the venom universe currently the director
did confirm this like yes there is a version of
spider-man inside this universe as we speak but
he wouldn't confirm which version of spider-man it
was tom holland toby maguire or andrew garfield
i've done numerous videos about tobey maguire
and andrew garfield easter eggs in the original
morbius trailers there are a couple easter eggs
that they've removed out of the morbius movie
i think mostly because of the way they changed
the events of the film because of what happened
during spider man no way home so remember they
delayed the morbius movie again it was supposed
to come out way earlier in the year but what
happened is is that spider man no way home was
one way too popular like sony was earning way too
much money so instead of doubling down they just
let it ride like okay everybody loves spider-man
their way home we'll just leave it in theaters
and we'll just delay morbius a little bit later
but also what they decided to do was change their
post-credit scenes and the vulture scenes were
originally supposed to happen earlier in the
film there was going to be another spider-man
easter egg with tobey maguire spider man suit the
reason why they probably changed that around is
because they probably were trying to figure out
who was going to be their version of spider man
in their universe and they're still working on
that contract so if they had shown toby maguire's
spider-man suit in the movie people would have
thought oh it's toby maguire he's the version
of spider man in this universe but i think
part of the idea is they want it to be andrew
garfield spider-man but if you remember i did a
video about how during the amazing spider-man 2
they were actually setting up a bunch of morbius
a bunch of andrew garfield venom symbiote saga
movies amazing spider-man 3 and a whole sinister
six franchise all the stuff that they have planned
right now that they're teasing this upcoming
sinister six movie they were gonna do that back
when andrew garfield was still the main version of
spider-man so i think they're just circling back
around and just saying hey why don't we just
do a bunch of that stuff just with the modern
current versions that we have going right now
but the sinister six movie that they're clearly
setting up here will have mcu vulture on the team
morbius probably a version of venom as well and
they'll have a lot of the other sinister six
characters that sony is doing movies for right
now like right now they're shooting a craven
movie with aaron taylor johnson and chameleon
we'll make a bunch of mcu quicksilver ovarian
jokes when that comes out their version of the
daily bugle is also tobey maguire's version
it's the same logo but it mentions chameleon
in the craven movie he's going to be his
half-brother just like he is in the comics the
movie's version of the daily bugle also mentions
black cat and rhino they'll probably appear
in that sinister six movie at some point i think
it was pretty clear about them setting that up and
a lot of people just want them to confirm which
version of spider-man it is now the main issue
that i think people had with this post-credits
scene because a lot of people were upset about it
is mcu vulture being so anti-spider-man all of a
sudden because at the end of spider-man homecoming
he protected peter parker's secret identity to
the scorpion pretending like he didn't know who
he was and kind of brushing the scorpion off even
if doctor strange's second spell made him forget
peter parker's identity when he was transported
he would still remember a version of spider-man
saving his life so that's a little bit more of
the hand wavy logic from sony and it sounds like
they're trying to say something about his memories
of spider-man without the memory of peter parker's
relationship with his daughter makes him now hate
spider-man for some reason but if you have any
other questions about the morbius post credit
scene or the sinister six movies just post them
in the comments below i will do a full breakdown
in easter eggs for the entire movie on saturday
at some point so be sure to enable alerts for my
channel so you don't miss that congratulations
jace the sage you're the giveaway winner for
my last big marvel video please email me on the
about page of my channel so i can get your contact
details and everyone click here for my full marvel
moon knight episode 1 video in easter eggs and
click here for my moon knight episode 2 trailer
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!